and finally today end with a little bit
more good news okay this is actually
good news this is real good news this
past Saturday Supreme Court Chief
Justice John Roberts in a motion that he
did not consult the rest of his Supreme
Court about actually issued a stay on a
ruling from a lower court that had he
not issued would have forced the
disclosure of countless dark money
political campaign donors this past
Monday but Roberts knew that the lower
court's ruling going into effect Monday
would harm the Republicans in the
midterm so he came out Saturday and said
I'm issuing a stay that ruling cannot go
into effect you're not gonna learn the
names of these people on September 17th
as the original lawsuit had set that
case was actually decided back in August
but Roberts waited two days before those
names would have become public to issue
his stay and he did it on a Saturday you
know obviously slower news day people
aren't paying as much attention why not
jump in there and try to do it but
that's obviously a bad thing right and I
told you this was a happy story well
here's the happy story here's the good
part the rest of his Supreme Court was
paying attention and the rest of his
Supreme Court liberals conservatives
alike didn't like what John Roberts did
and yesterday they vacated his stay and
said you know what we disagree with you
John Roberts Chief Justice of the
Supreme Court and apparently when we
band together we're a little bit more
powerful than you so we're getting rid
of the motion to stay that you had and
we're saying release the names of the
donors the rest of the court again
liberals and conservatives actually
coming together to do something good for
transparency and campaign finance
vacated his stay so now very soon we're
gonna learn the names of the dark money
donors who are controlling our elections
now the original lawsuit was against
Karl Rove's Crossroads GPS
the lawsuit was filed actually several
years ago by citizens for responsibility
and ethics in Washington crew because
they wanted to know the name but there
was actually a law that's been on the
books for decades that says this kind of
dark money going to these politically
active nonprofits is okay you don't have
to release the names of the donors
unless that donor gives you money and
says I want you to spend this money on a
certain thing in that case you have to
disclose the name otherwise you don't
have to disclose the judge in August
threw that out and said no disclosed all
the names everybody no matter what they
give you money you tell us who they are
that's how it's gonna be from now on
John Roberts stepped in politically
motivated trying to stop that from
happening had nothing to do with the
rule of law he understood that the
midterms are right around the corner and
releasing the names of these donors
could significantly hurt the Republican
Party but guess what his stay got shut
down by his own Supreme Court who
believed he was wrong not just wrong in
his ruling but wrong to act politically
from the bench because that's what
happened this wasn't about the law this
was about John Roberts politics and his
desire to protect the Republican Party
and the upcoming midterms so pay
attention as we get closer start
watching those political ads read the
bottom is very soon you just might see
the name and finally know who which
human being not organization is actually
funding those I want to thank David
Pakman max Patrick everybody for all
their help today for letting me sit in
taking over the reins now and a few
weeks ago as well so thank you very much
and if you're not completely sick of me
do follow me on Twitter at fair and
balanced subscribe to a youtube channel
youtube.com / the Ring of Fire thank you
everyone for letting me fill in David's
back tomorrow and he'll see you then